hello everyone and welcome to a very
short video where I will be explaining
what's happening here what's the
membership area and what's this whole
YouTube membership thing now a lot of
people have asked me before why I don't
have patreon why I don't have you to
YouTube memberships enabled and such the
reason why I never had it is I wanted
all of my content to always be free for
everyone and I said that if I will ever
have I think like patreon or or YouTube
memberships that I will still keep
everything free it will merely be means
for people who have done well for
themselves in life to support something
they enjoy so this is no different
everything is still the same everything
is still absolutely free you don't have
to be a member or anything to enjoy any
of my content all the videos will still
be free live streams and everything is
is free so do have that in mind before
engaging in any of these well so called
the perk classes now there are five of
them I've decided to make five like it's
sort of a youtube standard there is
excellent subscribers who the guys no
reverse gear Club
there's the Pirates and of course the
the top class Club is the magicians but
the perks for all of them are the same
so basically the perks are only symbolic
so like I said it's if you've done well
for yourself in life you are welcome to
support something you enjoy if it's this
channel you are more than welcome to
come aboard now what you will be
receiving as perks for for joining the
the membership area is the the standard
you will get a like a badge for example
when I do a livestream or something you
will have a badge that distinguishes
yourself from other members from other
non-members and you will also be able to
use customize the emojis like that you
will have like an emoji of mid oh you'll
have like an emoji of the great Nisha
maybe maybe some paper the frog or
something like that we still haven't
figured it out but there will be some
customizable emojis and another thing
that we are planning since we are very
soon starting our chest manga which I
will still not name you will be able to
be involved in the manga it's
for example if we will have doubts about
whether something will happen this way
or this way you guys will be able to
let's say be involved in the storyline
by maybe maybe voting on what happens
here what happens there and so on and
also you will be receiving any news
regarding the channel let's say before
anyone else like maybe a few days before
maybe a week so like I said all of the
perks in all of the classes are the same
and they are all fairly symbolic so you
don't really you don't really get
anything for now I will be looking into
maybe after we finally publish the manga
to be able to for example get you guys a
physical copy of it if you are if you
are let's say in in some of the areas of
the membership but I'll still I will
still see about that as we still haven't
even started it so that's something to
be to be decided in the future so yeah
that's basically it if you if you are
still interested in joining you are more
than welcome to join but like I said
everything is free and there is no need
to join anything to still be able to
enjoy the videos like you have so far or
if you are a new a new subscriber or
just a viewer on the channel so that's
it hope you guys enjoyed it and see you
soon guys